he's gone by many names the Long Island
serial killer the Gilgo Beach murderer
and now authorities say they've
identified him by his true name and
taken him into custody we're unraveling
the mystery that dates back more than 10
years long crying Deli covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber a major update to a true
crime mystery that has haunted the Long
Island New York area for more than a
decade authorities say that they have
arrested a man believed to be the Gilgo
Beach serial killer law enforcement took
Rex humerman into custody late Thursday
and his home was being searched on
Friday he's lived for decades across the
bay from where multiple sets of human
remains were found he's now charged with
first and second-degree murder in
connection with the deaths of three
women and he's considered a prime
suspect in a fourth Suffolk County
Prosecutors are asking for humor men to
be held without bail because of the
nature of the crimes as well as very
unsettling internet searches that
included child pornography heermann is a
married father of Two and a licensed
architect in Manhattan authorities say
they first identified him as a suspect
in March of last year and the task force
took over from there
our po our partners and my office we use
the grand jury to continue to
investigate and we executed over 300
subpoenas search warrants pertaining to
this individual to find out more
information
uh one of the things that we did is we
followed him because we wanted to get an
abandonment sample of his DNA
which we were able to do
we also got DNA samples abandonment
samples from his family uh this really
um supported our decision to keep our
investigative
Focus secret because we knew that one
person would be watching and we didn't
want to give him any insight into what
we were doing and we also didn't want
him to know just how close we were
getting so we maintained the the grand
jury secrecy and we maintain the
Integrity of our investigation
uh in addition to those those uh
um Gilgo searches he was searching
compulsively searching pictures of the
victims but not only pictures of the
victims pictures of their uh their uh
relatives their their their sisters
uh their children and he was trying to
locate those individuals I want to give
you some background on this case which
has thus far remained unsolved so an
escort named Shannon Gilbert disappeared
in 2010 while leaving a client's home
and as police searched for her they
found a body then another and then
another in all 11 sets of human remains
were found along a highway near Gilgo
Beach in 2010 and 2011 including
Gilbert's now most of the victims were
female sex workers but an Asian man's
body was also found as well as that of a
toddler detectives believe it's unlikely
that all the bodies found near Gilgo
Beach were connected to just one killer
you may have seen a documentary on this
case called Lost Girls released on
Netflix in 2020 in 2022 Suffolk County's
Police Commissioner created a task force
that included the D.A the Sheriff's
Office New York State Police and the FBI
to renew the search for new Clues and
hopefully push the investigation forward
criminal profilers at the time the
bodies were discovered said Killers like
this do tend to fit a certain type
I mean just statistically he's likely to
be a male between the ages of 20 and 35
with a serial killer like this the
thrill is in the kill so that what
really drives him is not sex but rather
the power over another human being it's
the power of God and he feels Mighty
strong at this point because apparently
he's killed many people and has not yet
been caught
unbelievable okay I'm here with my
co-host Brian buckmeyer Terry Austin
Brian will start with you how have they
connected him because this is like a
major update I remember following this
case back in law school 10 years ago
yeah it's DNA and cell phone records
supposing he had a number of burner
phones that were communicating with a
number of these women in close proximity
to when uh they died and all of a sudden
when they when their bodies are believed
to be deceased no more communication he
seems he want to laugh and speak with
them also there are heroes fragments
from his wife uh on me on all three of
the bodies and on waterman one of the
victims his hair fractures are found now
interesting enough they're not saying
that it's exactly their hair they're
saying
99.96 of the community can be excluded
from these hairs but not his wife and
not himself so they're thinking he must
have had some sort of connection and
maybe his wife's hair was on him and
then dropped off on their bodies in
other words it sure looks like it's his
material or his wife's material the
question is though now Terry he might be
connected to at least these three deaths
but what about out all of the remains
all of those bodies that I mentioned how
do they connect them to those yeah
you're right there are 11 bodies that
were found in this area and I think that
fourth victim they said they have very
similar information about her I think
they will ultimately include her in the
charges I think the others are going to
be more difficult so for instance they
found a male and they found a toddler
and they found who they think is the
mother of the toddler I think it's going
to be more difficult to connect those
bodies to this but they don't want to
add an extra cake because if it's weak
on that case it'll weaken the rest of
them right exactly the murder one that
he's being charged with is for killing
two or more people so as a defenseman
I'm looking to write about off the bat
which one of these cases can I pull
apart at least maybe beat the murder one
maybe try to go down on murder two maybe
he says he's extremely emotionally
distressed hey even investigators say
that they're not connecting all these
murderers to one one person so use that
if I'm an offense attorney to my
advantage and Terry real quick they're
going to search his house so they might
find more evidence they will find more
evidence he's done all these searches
that we've talked about and they could
find evidence as far as the other women
are concerned what a development I'm
very curious to see this I know his
defense attorneys have just been handed
the case but maybe they'll have room to
argue certain things like fight against
the DNA and the cell phone evidence will
continue to follow it's still ahead on
Long crime daily a judge had an affair
with a prosecutor and now a murder
conviction is being thrown out because
of it but first another day wraps up in
the Bradley yawn trial as the defendant
tries to navigate being his own lawyer
and questioning members of the victim's
family a few of Friday's most outrageous
moments are next
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody the Illinois
defendant who chose to rep represent
himself against multiple charges is
presenting his case to the court and
calling Witnesses and let's just say
things are not exactly going smoothly
here's a little bit of background for
you in November 2021 Bradley Yan and his
accomplice Karen Blackledge allegedly
carjacked sexually assaulted and robbed
the home of 77 year old Tina Schmidt she
died a month later and while Authority
prosecutors aren't pursuing murder
charges they believe that Schmidt did
succumb to the trauma that she endured
Yan is currently facing multiple charges
of home invasion aggravated kidnapping
vehicular hijacking burglary and sexual
assault his accomplice black ledge
pleaded guilty to home invasion and
sexual assault and is now serving 40
years in prison Yan on the other hand
chose to act as his own defense counsel
as he faces a possible life sentence on
Friday he questioned several of the
alleged victims family members including
her husband and daughter here are just
some of the Blockbuster moments from
court on Friday
Mr Smith uh just to refresh your memory
uh
you stated you were subpoenaed for a
phone records correct objection your
honor we've just dealt with this
Beyond how do you Quark sustained that
objection your honor you need to go down
A New Path I'm just
letting the witness know where we're at
your honor even here he knows so next
question sir
um
okay
and you did provide
those records objection your honor asked
and answered and we've gone down this
path
Mr Smith uh the objection
are you aware I mean
are you aware that they're
was no objection your honor I will
sustain the objection Mr no-nine Warren
objection your honor I'll ask the
bailiff to have the jury return to the
Jury Room like YouTube subscribe for us
your mother's
pain in the last month of her life
before she passed away in December was
was she in pain yes she was in extreme
pain I'm sorry she was in extreme pain
objection your honor testimonial
that's what this is due Mr Young so
testimonials say you're on
injection is overruled
beyond our next witness who will let me
that would be Kevin Douglas you know all
right Douglas is not here your honor and
is not available today all right is he
subpoenaed
Mr Young yes he's on the
as you can Sabine it yes I believe he
has by our office remember he did not
receive defense subpoena and there's uh
he's not available today all right so
you have not served him with the
difference subpoena is that correct no
you're not in that all right so he is
not going to be available apparently do
you have another witness thing give me
one moment judge uh
so he's representing himself he's
calling some witnesses from that it
doesn't look so good but you giving this
more of a granular picture how's he
doing so far well usually this statement
when you say he who calls himself as a
as his own attorney he has a fool for a
client that's a slogan right it's
something like that in any event he
actually did not do that poorly he
called on his direct case some of the
same witnesses that the prosecution
called and he asked the same question so
that was a waste of time but he called
the husband and at first you might think
okay why are you putting this man
through so much torture and I'm certain
that the jury was thinking the same
thing but he established a couple points
he said did you really call 9-1-1 he
said basically was there blood on the
couch when they moved or he asked
whether or not she died he asked where
were you did you come home at what time
so he's trying to implicate that it was
the husband now of course I think the
jury knows that's not the case but I do
think he was trying to point this finger
to someone else okay A for effort um
you're laughing Brian because I have to
tell you I've seen a number of Court
moments I don't think I've ever heard a
prosecutor yell that loudly and yell
objection yeah and my law school
unfortunately we didn't get grades for
effort only for doing well or not doing
well that's good so and I'm going to
grade them the same way
um he doesn't know what he's doing and a
lot of this he's splitting hairs he's
splitting hairs I'm just getting
argumentative and kind of going down
this rabbit hole with the witness and I
don't know why the prosecutor is getting
so hot under the collar it's not like
he's making an intentional mistake he's
not like he's trying to get one over on
the prosecutor he just doesn't know what
he's doing make the objection don't lose
your cool I get that you're frustrated
because of who you have to go up against
but he's not winning any battles but at
the end of the day he doesn't want the
jury to hear something and whether it's
his mistake or bad you know he doesn't
want the journey don't gotta look like
that while doing it though you can
object a different way you think the
jury's taken note of this oh definitely
taking note and I understand why the
prosecution got upset because the judge
specifically said not there but at
another time you can't ask about those
records because they're not in evidence
this witness can not lay the foundation
don't ask about that and he did anyway
so I think the prosecution at least at
that point got very upset because I
definitely think the defendant was
trying to either get a mistrial or
intentionally ignoring the judge see I
think a part of it is angry as they're
getting underneath they're like this is
great we're doing great I mean this is
this is a slam dunk for us when a
defendant represents himself unless of
course they're a lawyer or I think we
talked about maybe there was one case
where a defendant represented himself
and actually was acquitted but once
trials usually may eventually with a
judge all right coming up on Long crime
daily a doctor took people behind the
scenes to show them surgeries live on
social media but those live streams have
now gotten her into some serious trouble
plus a convicted murderer has that
conviction tossed after Courthouse
misconduct we have details on the
inappropriate relationship that sent the
case to the court of appeals
thank you
and welcome back to Long Prime Deli
everybody and Oklahoma appeals court
throughout a man's first degree murder
conviction because the judge and the
prosecutor in the case were having an
affair so in a narrow three to two
decision the criminal court of appeals
ruled that Robert hashtag and III will
get a new trial he was sentenced to life
in prison after his murder conviction in
2021. New Evidence came to light
revealing that judge Timothy Henderson
had a sexual relationship with a woman
in the district attorney's office who
participated in the trial Henderson
resigned in March of 2021 after three
female attorneys came forward making
allegations of sexual misconduct he
described the contact as consensual and
no charges were ever filed Henderson has
previously said that his rulings were
always fair and supported by the
evidence hash Hagen has was accused of
killing his 94 year old neighbor in
2013. no word yet on whether any of the
former judges other cases could be
impacted so Brian only three of the five
appeal deals judges actually voted to do
this why my guess and when I'm from
getting from the answer is that some of
the judges are saying this thing called
harmless error they're looking at it and
say okay I get it his due process was
violated and that's where the three
judges said you're supposed to have a
fair and impartial judge to weigh the
evidence against you and clearly that
can be if a prosecutor is leaving with a
judge but they also evaluate the
evidence against him they're probably
saying the two even if this was an
unfair judge they still would have got
to the same result so why are we
overturning a murder conviction
obviously three of them disagreed and
that's why we're here it was close you
think they made the right decision and
also I imagine they're going to look at
the past cases now and maybe other
things can get overturned no that
definitely made the right decision I
think it's a conflict no matter what
whether or not it's harmless error I
understand you don't want to have to
turn over all of these cases but there
is definitely a conflict if the judge is
sleeping with a prosecutor somehow
subliminate that is going to affect the
case so I think it should have been
unanimous I think the court of appeals
should have just unanimously decide it
look this is not right and put that
conviction aside they're definitely
going to look at other cases and go back
and try to determine whether or not
there were other cases where he was with
people or other cases where he made the
wrong decision because he has a conflict
of interest well does it matter if he
ruled favorably for the attorney or not
yes because at the end of the day the
you cannot justify the ends or the means
you cannot say we got the right person
even if the system didn't work it's a
criminal justice system it's supposed to
be better than any one individual person
so if it is flawed because an individual
within it is flawed and the process is
flawed even if we get it right it must
be overturned it's the same reason why
we reverse cases and suppression if it
was illegally searched we don't say well
the cocaine was in his trunk even though
the cop busted him over the head and
searched we just don't do that and real
quick Terry he could have had a
relationship with her but he would have
had disclose it and recuse himself right
well I think he should have had the
relationship subsequent to the case not
during the trial because during the
trial I think it's a problem no matter
what way you made those arguments you
you won me over you know the way you
argued that motion all right when we
come back a plastic surgeon who put
videos of her surgeries all over social
media guess what can't practice medicine
anymore the information that's now
coming to light about Dr Roxy and the
attention she was paying to her fans
instead of her patience
foreign
[Music]
who featured her surgeries and videos on
social media has now had her medical
license revoked the Ohio Medical Board
voted on Wednesday for a permanent
revocation of the medical license of Dr
Catherine growey she's known online as
Dr Roxy according to records the surgeon
has been reprimanded several times for
live streaming patient surgeries the
medical board decided she showed more
care for her videos than she did for her
patients the board also found that she
live streamed videos without patient
consent violating their privacy several
patients ended up having to get
treatment elsewhere to fix complications
that they ended up having one of them
filed a complaint in November about her
post-operation injuries that meant she
had to get a bunch of other surgeries
and that's when growey first had her
medical license suspended then this week
the board took it away growey told the
board that she had learned from her
mistakes and said that the process has
humbled her she promised never to live
stream another surgery again but the
medical board deem she won't have a
chance to at least in Ohio because she
can practice medicine anymore so Terry
other Physicians have recorded surgeries
before they never got in trouble what's
the difference there's a huge difference
here first of all other Physicians have
gotten permission to do those recordings
and generally speaking they're doing it
not for social media not for fame but
for educational purposes and so here
she's not trying to educate anyone she
is just trying to promote herself on
social media and without the consent of
the patients which is even I think more
troubling so I think it was the right
decision here not to just suspend her
license but to also revoke her license
not to give her any more chances frankly
unless she goes to another state because
Ohio can only control what is going on
in Ohio and it's just the idea that she
was focusing more on the videos the fame
and attention of it it makes me wonder
if other people are going to get in
trouble because my understanding is she
was warned for years to stop doing this
yeah she was but it kept becoming
warning and warning it only seemed to
become an issue because one can set
privacy issues huge got to get the
consent and two it seemed like she was
sloppy while she was streaming which led
me to the question of so are you telling
me if she got consent and set up a whole
film crew and she just did better that
maybe we'll have this be allowed I
thought they would just come out and say
maybe we shouldn't be doing these things
on Tick Tock I would have expected a
firmer band well
it just makes it from like a law point
of view like having a conversation with
your client and being like Oh the client
could sense to this conversation it's
like do you really want to have this
conversation live stream so you can show
how the law practice works well I think
now with social media everything is
getting extended so I think the courts
and the agencies that are licensing
these people are looking at it and
saying look if there's a legitimate
value to it if it can help anyone else
if there's an educational value and of
course if you have that consent they're
not going to ban it wholeheartedly
they're going to at least try to allow
some of these people to film whether
it's medical whether it's at you know
educational or legal I think they're
going to try to expand it and her legal
liability after doing all this privacy
violations and potential infliction of
emotional distress
I mean all of these can be can be issues
that they put out and of course like you
heard someone had to go to other places
to get those treatments fixed so you can
sue for well you have to pay to get it
fixed as well there's a laundry list of
things that people can come forward and
charge them with you know what shocks me
it's terrible judgment and to have
somebody Who You're basically putting
your life in their hands this is like
how did you even get to that place of of
getting your medical license doing this
becoming a doctor that's the part that's
just a little alarming when you think
about it Brian Terry great to see you
both thank you so much as always and
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on Long crime daily we're gonna see
you next time as we discuss Justice in
America
[Music]
thank you